stop looking at your shoes bro you know
Matt the shoes cute thanks bro
I like the shirt huh what color would
that shirt be oh I was a summers night
tou Neko summer colors maybe I am a
little dark
you're too dark for the summer I got to
start lashes bro can lighten things
night kicks maybe it's summer tea
really yeah yeah maybe a kind of on I
like a yellow sky like an aqua I like a
subscribe below like a baby blue look
this Yuri friend of the shirt I'm
wearing no I'm talking about me I'm
gonna start wearing no I'm saying maybe
some coral corals a little my pinky for
you pink is not a bad for it
Pink's not bad well done to orange paint
to match my sis huh your psoriasis
flared up that's better and you leave it
for Hawaii today yeah I'll be wearing
those wear shorts put out to put some
foundation on I don't mind it it just I
don't really want to Peter having people
go that guy has a disease hey no measles
on the beach sir is it contagious
no it's just I'm gonna get in the water
I think you're you can no I'm saying
like if like if you got in the water I
would get out I could smell my kids were
in this hot tub and I go hey light strip
down around where I jump in I hadn't
seen him in six my daughter's not in
here my tenure boat not in here with
that I go watching not without psoriasis
I don't want that in the water she ain't
life I was like don't worry - I mean
because how much research has been done
on psoriasis in hot tub right here oh
and I'm sitting there like this and I go
and I'm in the Sun I go it looks a
little better the right my daughter my
son is such a sweetheart he's like me
again let's make my son goes it is it's
getting a lot better he's six my
daughter goes no it's not in fact I
think it's worse jail I she's cold
I feel like this the Hawaii's gonna help
it though yeah Hawaii is very good now
you going on the island cuz you cheap as
[ __ ] the one with the volcano for a
discounter ah okay we're going right
where the volcano is but we got such a
good deal dude dude Beach fry its Beach
which gonna wear masks you gotta wear a
mask and yeah that's true and you have
to stay in the water get steak you have
to be on the self okay land is too
dangerous
well I was watchin somebody said it was
on this game said people what people
think of Hawaii right now
like from a movie like chaos and all but
everyone goes what it really looks like
it shows the island shows this little
bitty lapa things like this is what it
looks like if you're if you're around
that area you're [ __ ]
yes but everywhere else you're good well
there was that comedy I told I told John
my Brian's going to Hawaii this week so
I gonna cover the podcast get my back to
kill me and she goes oh why what about
the volcano
ah you think there's more than one
island you don't you think why is just
fine
I mean I know max Holloway and BJ Penn
would save that island themselves it was
that big of a deal people freaked out
about that Brazil they're shooting
people in the streets now like a city
like anything else yeah it depends what
it might be some crime there's stuff on
some crime yeah I don't know I could
have used you on on Thursday I could use
it The Laugh Factory doing stand-up and
then on Saturday can I use you as well
at The Comedy Store well I was all my
friends were gone man I was in Raleigh
and I sometimes you go to a city and I
don't know what it is but the crowds are
on fire why would you why would Raleigh
North Carolina be be as rowdy as a bunch
of Scottish fans in Scotland and an
ac/dc good you mean but like talking
during the show that's great oh good
laughing like that you go to Minnesota
all due respect because their
Scandinavian tend to be maybe they gotta
get ready for the derivative that laughs
goes right and then then huh and it
stops well you know I feel like there's
certain pockets like yeah like I've
never been to Raleigh been to Charlotte
amazing I've been to the comedies on
there yeah but Raleigh's a man Courtland
monster your head there so yeah I'm
going to Moreland weekend 21st 22nd 23rd
Portland monster Portland monster crowd
incredible a buffalo monster crowd yeah
funny why is that so weird and another
one's maybe I don't know because they're
used to a lot of female fans from
fighting a kid first time a lot of girls
a lot of women was it love was near
podcast awesome I listen your pockets I
go oh mixed mental arts
no she won't get real she was like
fighting kid oh sure how do you say
makes metal come on it's now the Brian
couch show so you changed the breakdown
yeah I took your advice
yeah gotta I gotta start branding that
might I might I might to heaven
a podcast where I actually debate people
I disagree with not and I don't want it
not to win but to try to see if I can
change somebody's mind hmm
I'm more interested in that like
something dynamic so it's one thing to
get somebody's point of view but maybe I
can because there are a lot of people I
disagree it'd almost be better I think
that'd be good but I think it'd be good
to have the expert from both opinions on
then you're them that's another and then
you like that's know back you that's so
that's another excellent no I'm saying
like at like jobs do you have your
opinions yeah but if I'm gonna tune into
I want someone who's [ __ ] like they
know who knows both sides there's a
great you may be like you want to First
Take
yes I agree with whatever it's a good
call something dynamic where I feel like
you know what you already don't on there
no well no because sometimes like in
everything in life there's smart talk
right so you got people to talk smart
but what's not number one what's getting
done number two you're speaking
theoretically you can have an argument
the problem with everything in life is
that you got two different people and
and they're looking at data the same
data and they arrive at totally
different conclusions yeah right look
they look at the same data and they have
very different opinion yeah and you're
never going to get to the bottom of it
but sometimes you I believe
there's got to be a way to persuade
there's got you can you can get closer
if you have a discussion as opposed to
our argument you can get closer to the
truth
there is a truth worries there is the
best way to do something right one of
the things about fighting is we knows
you know if it doesn't work and you get
clocked you go back to the drawing board
if you're smart and you go why didn't
this work and it's kind of like it
forces you in there in the direction of
truth that's why if I say to you Brennan
and now hear me out I'm going to the UFC
I've been training in kung-fu but this
guy is right well yeah but but then
sometimes there's not there's not one
answer and like sometimes that you're
not gonna get to the like if you do gun
control god I want to shoot myself
sherface already talking about yeah you
good like your podcast isn't gonna solve
no you don't open up any don't know but
you know why I think like things like
gun control are so hard because in a way
like we boat we all have conflicting
points of view so for me and you and me
right we don't want to see spree
shooting nobody who does we don't want
to see but we don't see maniacs have
access to guns and go shoot up at school
for example right but then at the same
time I own
guns okay I also I had this conversation
yesterday you know it comes complicated
like I own guns kill one I have guns in
case somebody comes to my house where I
can shoot him at the same time I kind of
want to make it harder to get guns I'd
like that
I don't think it makes me a screaming
liberal right I was having this
conversation yesterday at a barbecue
over at my house and we're talking about
cops stuff like that and I've never been
opposed to guns I've always been scared
a gun yeah and then I had an incident
where my we're at a robbery at my house
and how I saw how long it took the cops
to get down went oh [ __ ] man you need a
gun III I can't and it's not on them
it's it's more of the cops issue because
there's not enough cops that big la is
so it took them however long 10 12
minutes to get to my house in that time
they could have murdered everyone in the
house that's correct what I can't there
but when they show up I'm sure it's
gonna be all fine and dandy the problem
is there's so little cops in such a mass
area you got to take matters into your
own hands so then now I have guns have a
lot of good well that's how I got a dog
because if you're just banking on the
cops where you're safe now you're sorely
mistaken
and that's what I always say like I
might go down on them no my joke is that
my smartphone is it's good I can call
the cops but it feels a lot smarter my
pistol grip Mossberg 20 gauge shotgun in
my hand feels a lot smarter at 3:00 in
the morning when the guys coming through
my window yeah that's that's immediate
recourse and a mi my [ __ ] dog that's
let's try to bite bite his [ __ ] face
off that I feel safer that I need
immediate action yeah I need immediate
action and my and my training my kungfu
so you come foo know to pronounce kungfu
no what was I gonna say to you you know
we were talking about you go to Hawaii
or you can't have your psoriasis and the
Sun I'm go that was it's funny with
psoriasis or anything they said man oh
man does everybody have an opinion god
damn it what you doesn't have an opinion
doctors who are medical doctors they go
like this they shrug and they go I don't
know could be I go what about diet they
go did they go to every doctor I've
asked like every dermatologist and
including other doctors and they go you
know I don't know could be I mean I'm
sure that they're certain died there huh
it's just the lungs you've ever had it
yeah usually just oh yeah it's probably
could look
did you get all gonna get worse I don't
think just diets the answer lets people
keep telling I eat this well alright
it's probably a combination of [ __ ] yeah
I think maybe diet but then also you
need medication
my mother us take the modern damon i do
and it helps my mother my mother a
problem medication like you can't take
certain yeah they'll tell you this to my
dermatology go i'll make go away i can
shoot you full of steroids got big side
effects and i could really do the side
effects are you can get all kinds of
[ __ ] for with with with steroids all
kinds I mean with certain topical
steroids but the other thing is they'll
give you Humera that'll get rid of it
immediately though what's the problem
well it lowers your immune system so you
can also develop lymphoma leukemia and
lupus so you don't want me if you live
in the exaggerating what I'm saying I
mean you're gonna be fine man most
people my mother my mother grades my
mother I love as I get older I
appreciate my mother I'm more my mother
hits me with this she goes I'm talking
about like you know the gut biome I'm
working with this guy and then I'm
changing my diet and my mother goes it's
all good um I think it's stress and I go
no she goes well for me she goes let me
let me explain something to you she said
I believe that you know so your father
when he gets rest he gets dandruff your
grandmother used to get this weird rash
on her feet on her on her hands
other people get stomach issues whatever
it might be she was I think when you get
stressed its rise she goes but she's not
she goes you do have love going he's not
wrong and she goes she said something
really interesting
she said you have an issue and I said
what she goes you're a very
compassionate person as you know like I
I'm compassionate I give a [ __ ] and it
when people are in pain if I read the
newspaper if I have somebody's not doing
well it bothers me a lot and I and then
but but she said and that would be one
thing and that's how I am and I
understand that and you get that from me
she said the problem with you is that
you also ever since you were a little
kid you wouldn't just get sad you would
then get angry and you want to kill the
bad guy who's making the problem and I
and and and and when I would hear a
story I would I would spiral into this
dark place and you're still doing that
51 yeah so I have to stop and say it
does cause me stress man but then you
also get your show and then shooting
your special all that shipment and
travelling travel to [ __ ] you up and
[ __ ] you up but you know what and this
is gonna sound so I don't but but I
really really mean this I kind of give
up no I I just hey I just want to stop
this all gonna stop everything I say and
I lived in Montana I'm gonna move to
Montana I'm a ghost I just walk away I'm
gonna work through bur I just quit
that's the message is quit and we find
me an uber no I'll let your boy I swear
to god I can't this this arises thing
has forced me to contend with certain
things that are very positive very
positive [ __ ] it's just psoriasis but
it still not be just ya know but is he a
punk anything you guys don't know
anything you get any new you gather you
want to fix well what's really going on
it forces you to take an inventory of
how you're living your life I'm like
yeah you know here's spots on your like
that
I loved it this is the and I was making
fun of CM Punk for this it was like he's
so brave
oh yeah he's so well before you say that
I want to ask you a question about that
like your psoriasis it's like I get
[ __ ] well by the way I got some other
well here's what I was going straight
nurse don't send me a DM or like what
you know Brian together is Invisalign
halfway through the first show no I
didn't yeah it's like no you wouldn't go
on stage with it I do not mean don't go
on stage with it right no but Mike my
question is I've been hearing people and
you know he fought and he kept getting
up and there's there's there's heart
there and all that and people like you
know but but but my question is like is
that self belief probably but to what
degree what's the difference between
self belief and craziness and dilution
yeah do these off to lose it but this
this is my thing in this the point has
many on below the belt if we got to be
careful with throwing up the term brave
let's say a guy similar to who's 51 who
has your experience in Tae Kwan and
wrestling and you don't know I said
be you'll get to experience the entire
UFC treatment the same as John Jones
Brock Lesnar Cain Velasquez max Holloway
you're gonna experience exactly what
they go through now only gonna be able
to do that we're gonna fight a guy of
similar skill set and we're gonna give
you eight million dollars how brave is
that to take that I wrecked not Brett we
need be careful throw in the term Raven
I agree and and you know at the end of
the day
CM Punk showed heart awesome what is
this right is this heart I don't even
know and by the way I said my main is
she was this my main issue is this like
and and his fame got him there there was
an effort there all good
the only thing is that that that is an
arena for professional fighters
professionals he's still in have the
highest level at the highest level and
what it takes to get there like all the
people fighting all the time like trying
in all the different leagues and they
get their break on The Ultimate Fighter
who did you one guy wins and gets a
contract like the amount of work like
you look like guy Kevin gas one of these
guys like it's so I'm looking hard and
then you get but but he's still an
amateur and I don't think he's a
reasonable amateur circuit he would be
lower to of course he would he would get
destroyed by it yes he was yes he would
he's not Mike Jackson's an amateur - yes
he's terrible as well and a lot of
people think Jackson was trying I like
elongate like he was keeping the fight
going I think he was yeah yeah yeah I
mean I think he could have ended it
sooner and and Dana was mad about that
Dana is I'm with Dana on this yeah I'm
with Dana yeah I thought it I thought
the years to calm a [ __ ] idiot but
yeah I'm with love I ran the thing that
[ __ ] idiot we give these guys
opportunity you know and then and then
you go and you got cocky and you're
doing this what are you doing man you
never fight here again like we did you
we threw you a [ __ ] gold bone yeah
and you threw it in our face yeah man I
don't know I but that's where it comes
down to it's like that's a that's a
that's an arena for professionals who've
earned that place and it's really hard
to get there it's [ __ ] hard to get
there and and that's when you realize
that's when you go and you may have been
tough tough guy in your neighborhood
good athlete play college ball played
high school ball I'm just going through
right now know those guys have those
credentials what's that tough got as far
as your tough guy played college ball
played
neither's gentleman have not correct him
not even that but the problem is is it
hurts the sports so bad would letting
them even have the chance to compete at
that level where it's you would never
see this in any other sport like the NFL
you know me people dream of playing the
indoors
can you imagine of corazon state
warriors like man Wow Dwayne Johnson
it's just the biggest fan if we are you
guys cool if we put him at point guard
for this first game one is that okay you
met Jim the rock playing basketball is
no different than CM Punk fighting the
ascetic the rock has as much experience
dribbling a basketball then CM Punk does
punching people in the face so if the
rock was like dude well I went I
wouldn't train with Michael Jordan for
the past two years though I bet the best
train in the world that that's cool
you're not a basketball player it
doesn't count show filled it so if you
think of the rock playing basketball
that's ridiculous that's no more
ridiculous than seeing a punk fighting
on the main card in the UFC I'm very
similar so I watched every fight and I
and I i watched the beginning of that
fight and I just stopped watching that's
like I'm gonna watch this it's gonna
make me feel bad yeah I just
and then I saw some of the highlights
and I was like well there's no you he's
not a shape you look like [ __ ] I don't
know like I said I am fine good guy
train with him at Chris Kuehl he's
always a nice guy
I'm critiquing the athlete though but I
think both of these great guys can you
do did you what you can do in Hawaii
brother run run hard in the did you know
the guy that just chills out in the Sun
I'm gonna cut through the water like I
you ever seen me swim and do the
butterfly yeah I have kaduche I get up
hey hop it you guys have actually just
playing are you just gonna chill though
are you that you don't feel like that
I'll go on vacation I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna veg out I can't you know that
are you gonna do I'll be restless
alright I'll play with my kids well my
daughter won't play with me my son will
my daughter will did I get away from me
especially in shorts because you're
disgusting and don't embarrass me but my
son will play with me yeah so that'll be
cool and then I'll I will do stuff do
I held a little tiger down because he's
getting this straight fro I'm like here
at keep when he's a hundred percent 2471
so he's sweating he kept his the here
was like getting his face I'm like we
gotta cut his hair and he hates [ __ ]
clippers so I have Joe home down I
shaved his head shave this out I gotta
see a picture of an axel better and then
I I sent this our friends were over and
they're like do you really get his legs
look at this [ __ ] kid man - that's
the craziest he looks like a CrossFit
out no I'm not kidding these giants on
him what does he is he now is he's
squatting over 200 pounds
I'm not kidding that's I know can we
were obviously I kick what's going on
I'm like it I don't give me a just
economy just gotten traps those legs are
stupid little shaved head I mean he's
got it just his leg looks like the
letter S think of the letter S
he's got giant quads and then they go
into these his calves are every bit as
big as Will Sasso yes and then you could
rest a beer bottle out on his ass and
his ass goes all the way out and he's
how old it's too man that's the nuttiest
thing I've ever seen in my life and he's
got a mound of pubic hair goatee is that
what you're doing give him steroids
we're trying to go to the league maybe
some hormones in the meat but I'm trying
to go to the league so weird it's got a
full beard he's got a tape Fletcher
beard gotta get out the hood man it's
kind of crazy you can't rap you had a
ball got a ball
you got a ball son you gots the ball you
gots the buck gots the ball did you what
bro you watch any basketball yeah
LeBron's out by the way I did what since
from a LeBron Oh
did you watch any of it yeah so they
play they just gets [ __ ] blown out
Game four and then I'm like I feel bad
for LeBron like God for nothing definite
so the series is over it's best out of
seven so series is over god I got blown
out so then he goes the press conference
and the like a LeBron I don't he goes
any of the Castleman's hang on oh no and
then you know first question what
so up with the Kathy is this little
thing game to I punched a whiteboard and
broke my hand I've been playing with a
broken it's like what the [ __ ] man let
someone else tell that because now it
looks like you're making excuses you
know I'm saying like I'm a LeBron family
oh right when I saw him like you're
doing yourself no favors man yeah no
[ __ ] favors at all he's out I think
he's done Cleveland he's out I bet he
comes to LA like if they could get like
a Paul George or someone else here to
link up with he's coming to LA either
clippers or Lakers I'd love him to come
the Lakers do you do this heat does it
go MJ Kobe LeBron most would say MJ for
whatever reason I don't know it's a I
mean there's debates for anything
anything yeah because that there's even
argument is Durant better than LeBron
and also like Jeff questions I mean
there it just depends but he's out he's
[ __ ] he's coming he's either Houston
here maybe Philly but he's out of
Cleveland he has to decide pretty soon
there's a bunch of [ __ ] in there because
Connors trials this week in New York I
think of the community service next week
or two the next yeah the next week or
two will be LeBrons decision the second
decision big things man but going on
Jones yeah
when John Jones here either this month
or next month that so this hearing
decides whether or not he's reinstated
his punishment should be from you sada
Masada that's that's all it matters now
what is that up to Jeff Novitzky or is
that it's a commission it's like the hmm
probably having very similar debates you
sit around you come up with it's so it's
so lame those [ __ ] morons
the Commission's right so then really
commissions are like Conor McGregor
you're not allowed to fight in you know
a lot of fight for six months and we're
giving you two or $75,000 fine
encounters like cool I won't fight there
anymore like okay so you you owe us 20
grand and you got to shoot a commercial
for us Connors like yeah my minimum to
shoot commercials about for milling
all right just sign these photos for my
kids and you can fight next week that's
all because it's just all up for debate
you know all the guys like you're worth
Nick Diaz
you can't fight for life kiss smoke
marijuana how ridiculous is that it's
just all it's always such a [ __ ] yeah
well what about morale what about
judging Rogan was saying I wish they'd
add more than three judges hell yeah
that's my issue forever
well how did that's a commission issue
right that is net by state by state
that's that's a sport issue they'd have
to revamp the entire sport
well what Brogan wants I forget how many
but I could see high five yeah I think
five but I don't know what about Joe
think they should be in the arena what
about they should be watching TV see I
think anymore into uni I think that you
need five judges and remote location
that we don't know that and they're
watching on TV in person is too tough to
to get you see right and you're getting
swayed you biased from the fans yeah
there's a lot going on why such an easy
fix why couldn't they just do that why
couldn't say ten judges ten watching TV
Tennant ten at the gate you know I'm
saying
and put the judges like put like even
like three judges on one side of the
case three judges on the other I don't
think I should be there in person it's
to the sports to top tough the critique
like that all right
I think you have a remote location they
do be in the arena but they're not
enclosed is it boxing rules I'm still
confused because it's takedown boxing
ring knocks it on control yeah no not
boxing takedowns I'm saying though
you're still looking at you did they the
judges do not see the copy box numbers
so they they have to just gotta go on
what they're seeing right so they're
counting head strikes they're counting
leg strikes they're counting damage is
damage at factions yeah because that
would seem to be the case too
I mean they do it so it's a huge issue
what's new man you know yeah a bunch of
the I don't know but everyone complains
about it but it's like until you do so
what do you think of the fights overall
uh black luster for what the car was
supposed to be yeah I mean five
decisions it's tough man and one of
those decisions is 50 minutes of Mike
Jackson CM Punk there and then you know
Holly dominated media and soon I was
interesting too because Megan Anson is
such a gay woman but
you kind of see the different fields or
Fergie's it's tough though first
fighting you see and then tied to a Vasa
or lassie good fight fun fight decision
yeah and then Kobe come to beat the
bright side ah da guy and then yet
Whittaker Romero so with Kobe Kobe
Covington with with that kind of I don't
I think that he's gonna I don't think he
does that too
Tyron overtly as far as wrestling is
concerned if he comes in and tries to
close the distance
I think the tyrants a better wrestler
but better wrestling Colgin Kobe but I
don't think he has Kobe's cardio that's
[ __ ] yeah well she's fight and
apparently his coaches were saying that
like he's an American Top Team he just
doesn't get tired he draped by tired boy
Chris blades one yeah he did damn good
to me getting to be hard enough you like
that title shot he's a beast man I think
with Schad retires now yeah make sense
um little man you ready for your
semester brother I'm so ready
you decided to go on vacation before
this special that's just that we should
want to break it's a week cuz then I got
four dates after that so cuz we at with
one arena Chicago well first show is the
warm-up show July 19th it should take
you soon and then we have then we shoot
the show July 20th
and you shooting - yeah that's Friday
that Friday then I take a break and I
fire back up a start from scratch hey
with this boy then you're shooting a
show so you can take a break from static
right wouldn't it make more sense if we
want to say we uh if we really should
special after the season of your new
show maybe I'll tell you why because we
gotta sell it
so I shoot it gotta edit it and then
yeah and then you chop it and then they
have they have a release date on their
schedule but if you have any say in it
would it make more sense I think so
hopefully your new shows a hit and then
people are moving familiar with you and
then you really stretch that right good
correct and existed yeah you're right
what you have time because when does
when does the new show air so this
business is so changing so quickly in
that sense
Aires but when does what the show well I
started to my first episode I shoot is
August 27th then I believe we take
September off and then we start shooting
again in November October however for a
midseason however with the Roseann
debacle they may need us to move it
sooner to bump up yeah could be so then
when would the show air though I don't
know do you have no idea it would be
what's called a midseason replacement so
that would be November June July August
a total special be ready by then yeah
but then the season would wrap in early
to a 19 sounded like that
well you don't wait that long to release
a special now that's interesting yeah we
can release the one that shows out yes
all timing and it's all timing man it's
also the algorithm like if it's Netflix
it's the algorithm you know and again we
were talking about that like that
there's so much on Netflix and I don't
know I know a lot people have shot that
thing on Showtime great place to do it
but it depends it just depends just does
you know my thing is fairly political
it's fairly or is it I think so it's
it's it's it's timely it's very very
timely and relevant let's put it that
way well then you get it out soon best
thing I've ever done though so but then
you need get out soon if it's timely
yeah it that's not what I'm worried
about is very relevant period it's
interesting generally yeah yeah yeah
you're gonna want to shoot it in July
and then try and get it out like two or
three months after yeah I don't know
that's kind of out of my hands at that
point really well because they're smart
they'd wait to your show yeah and that's
a conversation I'm gonna have with them
to there's a whole marketing strategy
yes well whoever you go with yeah
so it's interesting it's you just you
just focus on the product do the best
you can
do the best you can do what you can that
you can handle but yeah we can handle
those stuff ii don't know yeah yeah yeah
and all that stuff that packaging yeah
what it looks like yeah know what you
know yeah putting you on the cover
that's gonna be weird but we wanted to
that bryan callen
american boner just Brandon Brandon but
like like that like I'm lost like what
like you're looking from
the American butter dude have American
Bar why is Brendan lunna when it says
when they were sending me Sasso and
Lilly are sending me pictures of my net
worth which is wrong but they at first
they said I was worth 200 grand then
they say I'm worth 1/5 or something but
it's a picture of you when you were like
26 Jesus crazy you know that
no Bryan Callen put in to Bryan Callen
Network you see net worth it here's a
seabright and shot someone said it's the
same as Rogen - when weekly gun row
against the picture of me people are
crazy that's right I'll never change it
beverage there's a belly you can
apparently girls were looking at you and
I we were asked oppa and and we were
eating you and I and apparently these
two girls clocked us at the bar thought
we were hot and they they were looking
at us and they they googled our net
worth the bartender told me and you came
up at 6 million or something and I came
up at two hundred thousand and they go
well the old guys poor so [ __ ] that and
they decided they weren't gonna come
over and talk to us
what cuz we thought the poor guy went to
help on that Marco told me that Margo's
man she was like ah he's poor
- when I'm gran he's 50 years old la
fere like I know there are long that guy
what about the young one who's loaded
yeah but no but then because they were
fighting about who got you and their
[ __ ] deal with the old brokedown how
are wrinkles and and shingles I don't
want wrinkles and shingles I don't want
wrinkles and change
hey lady lay in handle both wrinkles the
old man watch yeah we take them out he
can take two everybody goes okay that
contagious gonna jack off in the corner
do us [ __ ] hilarious
you're not getting away you know I'll
lay two hundred thousand dollars
Oh God who cool so in saying that words
thank god those skanks thing come by
well I thank God it says I'm worth 200
grand I'll keep it just like that not
only that's a bomb to go change that
right now my networking you can be I
don't care
hey how about how about on at the
economy store when it says like belly
room headliner the show moves loaners
called [ __ ] and so I'm talking to
Stevie and a bunch of comics outside and
someone I can't picture I'm like yeah
sure like oh can we do it in front of
sign like yeah and I'm like this and
Jeremiah Watson's laugh and I'm like
what are you laughing goes dude look at
the sign I'm like what it says belly
room headline
Brennan's [ __ ] Brendan Shaw and I was
all hey man hit that big and then he's
like no the show before TS call it's
called the [ __ ] show like it's like a
bunch of girls and like [ __ ] man like
look yes like [ __ ] Brendan Schaub the
hot girls in comedy god damn it it's not
cool man yeah did you do [ __ ]
buhbuh [ __ ] Jenna how about chill
winters first boxing event this weekend
so yeah yeah so you you took a break
from did you get loaded up on creative
first or you know believe it or not I
took kratom with me there but it didn't
take you sure you gonna stop taking so I
was gonna stop it last week however okay
this weekend whatever it was such a busy
weekend so I was like a busy weekend out
there's gonna be other stuff I was gonna
be drinking all right me and the show
time below the belt people we were
drinking to there so yeah there's gonna
be drinking I'm like it's gonna confuse
the way I feel whatever sounds like I'll
wait till Sunday so I waited till Sunday
so this morning I was known it was too
busy that's why no I'll take my frog now
did you take it are you done bro oh god
you know what are you are you still in
the warm embrace how about how about
yesterday I'm gonna barbecue and I gave
Joe's brother and her cousin some kratom
cuz they were talking about energy and
stuff like them like bread in the lava
I'm like you guys ever taking creative
and then her brother started laughing
it's dude here at date don't have you
ever tried it and then I broke out some
pills for them boys and put in some bad
Oh No
we've been getting a ton of emails oh my
from so many emails from people that
take it I do not addicted and then from
just horrible storable stories it's just
a pet it's somewhere in the middle well
it depends on your chemistry may be
right yeah everything with everything
that's nailed with psoriasis psoriasis
you never know you guys are trying to
get me on what you need bro you guys are
trying to get me on kratom what if that
fixed it what if it fix it like I'd take
it you don't know Tracy's about that if
you take testosterone and human growth
hormone it'll go away
I'd be on
that [ __ ] right now my skin would be
hotdog red yeah and I'd be shredded but
if you don't you're you're good you
don't need that at all the kratom I
don't think I've never know I don't need
a addictive drug
it's a does it give you energy to chill
you out a little bit for me it chills me
out
really yeah that's why I like it hey
gives you energy bro
I don't know they say the lower doses
give you energy and a little bit more
gives you uh
the cheddar want chill out it's all it's
all judge yeah so it's actually where
you take less is better take you the
sworn huh I don't think it's any feel
since now that her eyes are wider I feel
different no joke like better know like
uh it's called withdrawal no I can't
each other I know what withdrawals feel
like I remember I took a vicodin before
for bad pain to do it no but when I
stopped it I felt like crap mm-hmm-hmm
so I remember that feeling that I
researched was withdrawal right this
doesn't feel why is there a for sale
sign on your ass you can't the S is for
more cash I wanted some I reach over and
grab so we have a bunch of Sookie you
haven't taken your eyes off it
kratom you're boring into it with your
eyes take it in and your fight ye let me
know I'll snort that [ __ ] it might not
be legal there there are two ways what
are the two ways that you can absorb
something the fastest you know your ass
your ass now oh yeah I thought inhaling
you know order that would surprise your
your nose you knows yeah you know it's
not your mouth your nose
oh we said mouth earlier yeah you snort
it snorting like that's right right
better you ever played create them in
your rectum get to know no he only put
you ever injected between your toes
what no hey bro how big of an addict are
you injected in your toes yeah that's
what happens
get [ __ ] well my friends a nurse she's
a trauma nurse and she was showing me
what happens there they have to this guy
came in and he had a hole from his wrist
to his elbow he was a heroin addict in
his arm
iris his elbow and the doctor was like I
got to cut your arm off and you're in
the bottom of your foot off I have to oh
wow he's like he was arguing with him
and on
on the operating wait why were they have
they cut it off well because he was so
gangrenous that you can't save the
phalanges oh the flesh is dead yeah Tony
Jefferies uh wife Sarah she says she's
got another promotion got her master's
so now she's like the queen bee of
nurses and I was like I can't imagine
some the stories and she was awesome the
stories for at dinner this is the other
day at sushi she was some of the stories
well last week I was working at midnight
and this Joey came in goes I don't feel
good I fell and I think something got
stuck in my rectum Wow oh you fell and
guess what the x-ray showed Oh we'll be
a tide detergent bottle a tide bottle
like you don't want those small egg down
I bought like your skinny never had a my
yeah well he just fell yeah and it went
up his rectum rectum well sometimes some
have to get it out no sometimes if you
have a tide detergent bottle and there's
a lot of Lube on it and you're running
by and you pull your [ __ ] open super
hard like you take your I call peeling
the peach you grant you your hooker you
hook your fingers right at the right
right wherever your butt hole open
lobster-claw nope and then you just and
then it just you've fallen just be that
smaller one there's I said he they went
well we need gets our you're gonna die
he's like I don't happen I'll just
they're animals up there as well and
then she said she also another gentleman
came in you know those like the twenty
ounce coke bottles I was stuck up his
old pooper I really can't get it out
though and then uh she said the one guy
with the the coke bottle up his anus it
was there for six days well that's not
good because I just thought I'd pass it
she's like no you can smuggle a message
in your rump that way or kratom if you
want yeah you know just keep it in glass
there's all kinds of things you can do
with your with your bum oh I didn't know
that the the old caboose could carry a
tide bottle oh the caboose clearing
body's pretty impressed
yeah the caboose can carry a shitload my
fist all kinds of things yeah a bunch of
cash fat dick thousand dollars and
rolled $100 bills probably a million
dollars if you're really really
motivated faddle how much do you think
that's the only how much cash can you
store if I said to you Brennan
like I said now uh you can keep all the
cash you can fit in your ass $100 bills
yeah I would one I would would say why
was open let's say one shoot me up huh
how many ones do you think it fin that
out say exactly what I do I go get me
some some good cocaine I'm talking on
the cocaine that's yellow it's so pure
and I do I dip my finger and I'd I'd rim
myself I'd rim it and I put it in there
so I really numb my head her up you know
I'm the [ __ ] I will you got a lube it
- don't tell me how to do it bro
I've numb it up first then you Lube it
up and then I take a big old - but I
stuff as many of those goddamn can I
have hundreds no one once hey can you
google Wow but put on most of all the
money so and smuggled inside there but
$10,000 in ones I want to see what that
looks like first then I want to see what
$10,000 then I want to see what $100,000
and hundreds looks like well you got to
remember you gotta roll it in rubber
bands bro yeah well I'll do all that
don't worry about that I'll take a baby
bottle and I'm as tough as many as I can
in there it's gonna hurt I don't think
it's gonna be a picture of it sure they
will be that's probably the closest to
it what is that they'd ever spend
$10,000 in ones that's not I can't set
that in my ass no neither can you no
also one again so if it's ones nothing's
going in my ass yeah that's it's
hundreds those are hundreds of - that's
a nobody spitting on their ass that's a
disaster so let me see a hundred don't
be surprised see that oh wow ten
thousand yeah
oh [ __ ] bro so let me see a humble
Demelza let me see a hundred thousand I
get to the real of my [ __ ] no way if
you tighten that up
I don't think so ten of those that's it
that whole tight roll I'm telling you
chinguga l--
most amount of money so in smuggling
hole please let me see 100 let me see
$100,000 in hundred-dollar bills
cuz this is gonna be a lot dude yeah a
hundred thousand ten thousand no ten
thousand ain't a problem 100 thousand
dollar bill no no no you let me see the
most someone's ever snitchin there you
go now that's it
ooh I'm doing struggle I'm gonna do it
there's no way yeah
let me see let me see the most so in
actual human because you don't realize
they're probably they've probably done
it before so that [ __ ] prepared for
the case the load you can't fit that in
your ass can you lose who knows man let
me see what would it be worth opening
your [ __ ] for 40,000 dollars 500 not
40 grand the 10 most impressive body
cavity smugglers there we go
coins I laugh at a grenade oh my god
that's amazing
oh look at this poor guy Oh No so he did
one latex glove finger black tar heroin
alright keep going oh man cigar tube no
go back gin just Google most someone's
smoke smuggled in their ass yeah how
much cocaine can you fit in your rectum
this one no similar grams well girls can
put up area for a baby
well she had well she used to put in her
tummy you swallow it that's a lot and
then you [ __ ] it out to him yeah that
was a is there no record for as much the
most money ever record of smuggling
sure there is that's a lot so you'd have
to put a tube in there you probably can
only fit it's all drugs a lot of drugs
it's easy yeah do people actually
smuggle money hell yes dude in their
butts yeah right yeah it's mainly drugs
into drugs maybe amazing how much time
we spent on I thinking about how much to
put it up well it's interesting because
I don't know what the human body could
it's capable of doing me to meet you I
am - I don't know man you're some kind
of nitrogen I got a feel that that's a
torch smoker right let me pee first I
got it before the piss giant dong
speaking of smuggling
what do you got
so the first one is the saddest news all
week last week
so Anthony Bourdain passing away
committing suicide that was like such a
shocker I know man
how crazy is mental health when a guy
like if you could talk to anyone
especially if your older one who has the
perfect job they say empty border yeah
you know travels gets the experience you
so loved by everybody everybody ever
said nobody ever wants it out like
Anthony Bourdain no you said that you'd
be like what like that it seemed I don't
like kids and it seemed like you had
everything you had money fame doctor
travel yeah nice dude he survived a lot
says what he said he said something
interesting I guess first of all I think
he had said something about him thinking
about suicide all that he had always
thought about it but he said something
really interesting to me that I heard he
said I never expected to live past 30 I
always I've always felt like I stole a
really nice car and I've always been
looking in the rearview mirror to get
pulled over for it this makes sense
people feel that way yeah kill
themselves yeah what's is no but he
seems to have always flirted with that
ID well you you you he's a drug addict
alcoholic right and was yeah yeah and he
had out that background then also to the
guy who suffers from depression or
whatever he was out an issue there's
girlfriend there's rumors that you hear
about those rumors yeah I guess she was
seen she was photographed for days
before in can with a reporter who's kind
of a stud
yeah a journalist guys Argento yeah so
that I think when you do have those kind
of conditions and then maybe who knows I
don't want to spread rumors but then you
know something happens with his girl who
he loved and sees that put you in a
downward spiral it's a bummer because he
was in Germany or France shooting parts
unknown and then they said he's supposed
to go to dinner with his good friend
didn't show us famous chef yeah I think
um I think again this is a mystery and
like I think suicide is probably a
mystery to the people that do it
sometimes I don't know if that we're
aware of our of our own motivations
especially when it comes to something
singlets [ __ ] up what bothers me most
about this and the Kate Spade well I get
so angry at them is they had kids yeah
that's so about being a narcissist is
there's gonna be a worse thing to do to
the kid I would have they're so [ __ ]
up and they think by leaving this earth
they're taking the burden away from the
family members and the kids you're
making it so worse the kids eleven so
you know it's so [ __ ] I have a
daughter that age and it's like it would
be impossible not to think my father
doesn't love me but I will also say most
selfish level of despair that loves
non-severe is is something I've never
experienced no so she said he stayed
alive for his daughter too sure he must
have been going through some hell yes
and so I hope it's not just a breakup of
a girl or girl Cheatham whatever the
case but to take your own life is such
an extreme act that I would imagine that
you have no other choice it's it's
literally this rational choice of saying
I can't do this anymore and their only
way out there's a door there and the
only thing that's kind of like maybe
it's like being in on fire all the time
I don't know I never make it because you
you think you had the perfect life with
his job money fame well yeah I think
this is also where a lot of spirituality
comes from I think that it's not a
mistake that a lot of Tibetan monks a
lot of monks a lot of shamans a lot of
even priests oh if you look at it a lot
of them have gone through a crisis a lot
of them went through some form of a
breakdown sometimes when they were in
their teens in their 20s but many of
them went through a serious breakdown
where they had a choice between and how
many people do you see who have
everything I've met many who have
everything including including artistic
prowess and everything else and they're
a mess here's something though I think
that's the exception I think we got to
be careful that things aren't this dark
and gloomy I know a ton of people who do
have it all and they're happy as [ __ ] so
be careful so then the question everyone
goes and listen every any actor athlete
celebrity everyone has their issues but
we have to be real clear we're going
everyone everyone's struggling their own
way
yeah but I know some people are killing
it and they're they couldn't be more
happy
so they live in huge houses drive fast
cars and [ __ ] every hot girl I know and
they're happy as well I don't know
that's true I mean I don't know I'm
telling you I know people were happy but
but but but happy is it is also will be
carefully you have to define what
happened is sometimes they're happy
maybe maybe they're happy now maybe in
ten years they won't be well but that's
life yeah we gotta be careful what I'm
saying is that maybe also there's
another thought which is that there are
also serotonin levels and some people
have serotonin levels at a4 and people
like me I'm lucky enough to have a
serotonin lemon at eight so no matter
what happens and they've done so many
studies like jonathon height guys who
that like when you win a lottery people
who win lottery the lottery like money
that they don't have to work again and
they compared them to people who they go
back to their setpoint so you get really
happy then they go back to what they
were happy sir have certain happiness or
levels of mood are contingent upon a
physical phenomenon within the brain
like your serotonin levels lost what is
a bad example because those people
aren't working they may accomplish so I
didn't finish it though cuz they
compared people who became paraplegic
Schloss for use of their legs
devastating accident and people who won
the lottery and after six months both
went back to the sort of the set point
that they were at yeah so after the
initial thing you kind of reset you
regather yourself and you're back to
where you were and who you were yeah and
so so a lot of that's that - who the
[ __ ] knows man maybe he did heroin maybe
he was doing heroin he was younger
because he was so unhappy then you know
maybe a lot of you love substance abuse
and there's a lot of science to this who
drink too much who take drugs because
they don't feel [ __ ] that they feel
terrible when they're sober and that's a
chemical thing and they're trying to
self-medicate so I don't know man I just
have them in there and I agree and
you're right there are a lot of people
who have they go they get their goals
and they they're happy having what they
have you're right I know some people I
think I'd be careful everyone's
everything's dark and I'm happy as [ __ ]
well you know these things can go wrong
in dodge sure and you know you're
talking about being human you talk about
having a bad day
oh it's depression okay you'll get out
of it get back on track I don't suffer
from mental you know problems
but when we gotta be real careful listen
LeBron James lost Game four you got
blown out trust me with the billion
dollar deal in what he's doing with his
life in the private jets he's just fine
well how about this so my mother my
sister loved to be traumatic and I love
them but they loved they loved me they
were this is what they do they go I
think you're very stressed I think that
you should look into that
and I'm like then I go and I think that
you're you you really need a break and I
go okay hold on listen up I'm telling
you right now I'm not that stressed I'm
telling you right now I love my life
stresses no no it's a good stress
there's no depression no it's not true
and I want you to depress and I'm also
not that stressed yeah I'm just not I
have a lot on my plate like it yeah and
I have everything I want
yeah right so I mean I I do and but they
want to look into and be like you know
your psoriasis is this maybe there's
some of that I'm sure the other service
maybe there's something going on with
the what's interesting too the the thing
that but what is the bomb off see them
killing themselves on the kids that's
whole nother issue but the other thing
that's a bummer is when celebrities kill
themselves they've done this study where
and it's out right now I think Whitney
comes to read this out when celebrities
kill himself
so suicide goes up it with everything
because young kids rushing the younger
demographics they see these celebrities
going well that actually is an option
now yeah and if the celebrities doing
that and then you see is when Robin
Williams did it 30 percent in the
Northern California area rose in 30 by
30 percent well you know he ki hung
himself to a Kate Spade with his
bathroom you know and they're saying
they're saying what's not good is the
way the media gives the details they
should do no details on the way they
killed like with a vici how he broke a
glass ball and slit all this [ __ ] and
whatever they don't want up there saying
the media would do so much better with
avoiding an uprising suicide rates if
they didn't release all the deal with
abt was ABC a suicide is suicide
I didn't we don't need to know how these
guys do it do we want to are we curious
of course but as far as with society and
the younger demographics we shouldn't be
really it used to be like that you know
it you know I'm not respect yeah and you
know and when you die in a battlefield
they don't give you they don't that's
why they don't post pictures oh gosh
they don't bend they don't and they
don't tell you the details because it's
very very sometimes it's it's horrible
person electing oh they're not hurting
anyone else is sick I think that's a
technical I agree with with discretion
I agree with I don't need to know all
the details and I certainly didn't need
to see Kate Spade's I didn't see it but
I know that her note was made fairly
public to her daughter and stuff like
that I don't know if you need that
either that's her private businessman
when there's kids involved it that that
makes me more upset at them for doing it
sure but sure man what else you got chin
yeah it's first that um so how far Nadal
was in an Italian magazine huh he looks
so tan there big kick out his hand there
he was an Italian magazine and they
asked him if women and men players
should be paid equally and this was his
response it's a comparison we shouldn't
even make female models are more than
male models and nobody says anything why
because they have a larger following in
tennis - who gathers a larger audience
earns more I totally agree with that
it's called it's called merit and
competency and but shouldn't that be a
no less I think that should be in movies
car easy common market every sport
cheerleading should male cheerleaders
get paid the exact same well no one
really wants see a male cheerleader dude
but but but so this is a really
important point because that's that's
right you're worth Kevin Hart makes more
money why does he make more money than I
do tell me why because more people want
to see Kevin Hart right yeah so he can
charge how much $100 to take more than
you okay so he earned that or whatever
you want to say I don't know who's oh I
didn't it doesn't matter whether you
think he's earned it doesn't matter the
demand is there correct
it's only goes dude well I think four I
think Brian counts finally Kevin Hart
very cool but for whatever reason Kevin
Hart can go on this irresponsible torn
sellout state you you shout you can sell
you sell out everywhere you go you've
been doing stand-up for a year and a
half or whatever so there are there are
people who've been doing it a lot longer
and they they don't get to they don't
sell as much well do you want to get
into the details of that do you got
yourself there somehow you figured out a
way to sell more tickets you should earn
that so
Marxist and this is what it is this
Marxist idea this idea that no well men
already had an a leg up so women should
be paid as much as women tennis players
should be paid as much the mill from
from whose from whose wallet from whose
wallet what are you talking about who's
gonna eat that nut yeah Marxist there's
a funny
there's a but there's a Marxist sort of
like undertone to all this this is my
problem with equal pay no matter what
did you earn it [ __ ] yeah it's
called a hierarchy of competence and
merit like like Serena Williams did she
can carry some demand right yeah
so if Serena Williams is in a stadium
right let's say here in LA
Serena Williams is in this stadium and
then [ __ ] who's that Pete Sampras
who's the number one guy in the world
right now now give me some Roger
Federer's and then Roger Federer's in
this building who do you thinks gonna be
in higher demand who do you think can
charge more and that that's Claire's day
and if I'm a spots or if I'm responsible
for tennis I mean what do you want me to
do so I should pay her the sames much
what doesn't work that way yeah but to
both rank number one no I get that but
he is selling more tickets yeah but also
I hate to tell you if she would sell
more tickets she don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care matter what is all they
care about is ticket marketplace the
marketplace and if you think otherwise
then you're you're a dummy because
you're out well you're a Marxist that's
what see a Marxist would say it doesn't
matter everybody gets paid the equal
amount and especially since she's a
woman she should be brought up too and
they're going into they there's there's
this whole movement to go into
boardrooms and go there are too many
white males here yay
so we need to we add to it for some
people of color we need women
okay what about word do we need dwarves
as well what about the ways what about
the white males who earned the right to
be either what about the degree the work
they put it today not get an equal share
didn't could you do all right what else
get Jim alright the next one is Dennis
Rodman and the article here says Dennis
Rodman says he will fly to Singapore for
a Kim Trump summit to support his
friends he's actually there now he's in
Singapore he made it
oh thank god Dennis's yeah well now
we're good they weren't it they didn't
invite him even Trump said it really
nicely like he's a nice guy but he's not
invited yeah anyhow this is the little
poster he made up and Kim and it says
unite and he it looks kind of like he
did this as a joke but this is him
actually feeling like he's bringing them
together tonight feels like he's more
important than he is
I wore a Dennis Rodman sure roots a
fight shirt the other day and I was
walking and someone goes but I'm like
alright not a shop fan that's fantastic
and then the guy the guy had like a
yellow shirt and I saw him in line at
Starbucks and I was like what's up man
you know trying to I thought maybe you
know fight wise maybe he didn't like a
pic I did he's like dude Rob it sucks
I'm like what I didn't know he said I
was like why he was dead friendly like
tell you
oh no I liked when you played for the
Bulls I don't like what the [ __ ] he's
become now this is visit [ __ ] [ __ ]
you like :
one of the most oppressive but the
leader of the most impressive regime the
most impressive country in the world
enslave their population and starve
their population yeah good stuff
do you like Mao and and Hitler and
Stalin too awesome and Pol Pot same guy
with rod with us Jesus Christ man huh
Rodman he's just a dummy who gives a
[ __ ] about Dennis Rodman hello Ben
Wow somebody [ __ ] him and they said he
was just alright average and I know yeah
and I got on good authority look to bake
the dish bangin for a while - no I know
weather girl
nope but I I was and I spent some time
with her I would assume you know my
first question what is a hey how's his
dick no she said you know what she goes
you know whatever II was expecting to
see a monster there's a it was it was
alright but it wasn't great Wow nice
catch in this one a woman it was
attacked in Flores she went missing
oh and she was was walking her two dogs
and then she went missing and then later
on people found out that there's this
huge croc or alligator in this area in
Florida and they were they found the
alligator
and then open them up and found an arm
inside oh [ __ ]
so it 8 is a tour arm and then they
found the body like a daily quest
they'll twist your arm off and swallow
that it's for the body so they find they
find the torso a lot of time yeah but
also I saw something on this too that
that neighborhood they the homeowners
association sent out a whole warning
hell on what alligators every week then
apparently attacked her from behind so
she was walking and it just somehow
crept up on her oh my god that's just
scary how old was she the 47 not that
old
thank you would be tough that Gator gets
behind you and grabs you and it takes
you in oh my god that would be so
[ __ ] scary well foot so that's yeah
that's a huge animal let me see this is
terrifying I think they showed footage
of it from this afternoon trauma
chopper like the alligators swimming
there I guess once they taste flesh
that's the problem a wildlife a fluid
this is my thing though if you move to
Florida
norman's alligators doing alligator [ __ ]
man well it's pretty rare what you don't
expect the homeowners association sends
out a warning goes hey hey man around
this [ __ ] around you stay on the path
[ __ ] no it's bad if I come home today
and they're like hey did you see the
memo on the front door what's the memo
bro there are [ __ ] lions wandering
around here just stay down this road
though but they are around but in floor
I would not go outside Florida you can
carry a pistola I'm carrying ain't gonna
do [ __ ] I've carried what I'm carrying
me my my pistola you grab me alligator
grabs me I pull out my pistol ax and I
and I unloading this holdup job Rangers
have proceeded undertaking campaign
telling people not to feed alligators as
they might lose their fear of humans
which could lead to more attacks yep so
stop bringing out that raw chicken and
slapping the water alright guys you saw
that one video right now where they
threw food out and the alligator grabbed
another alligators arm and just get off
did you see the what do you see you see
dude do we talk bail in here what's
wrong oh no was that what deal with that
for ten years I saw the 10 years for
tenure get on the door the alligators
went okay this this guy oh no Eddie
Bravo sent me there so all yeah I
thought little pup little tiny dog right
for 10 years fast in the same Allegan
the owners like this is so funny and
then the value it you know what I'm sick
of this I'm a gator man if that's that's
a crocodile too salty in Australia and
it said I'm a saltwater croc the owners
like no no you [ __ ] man there is not a
dog on the planet that an alligator that
a crocodile is hearing a peep from not a
peep
yeah no [ __ ] Brian not a [ __ ] peep
what other [ __ ] of course every dog
we get [ __ ] by oh wait I'm not a
dinosaur did you see the great white
that that there is a seal swimming
around then there's this great white did
you see that great white in there oh
there's screaming on the boat as the
great whites trying to catch the seals
he'll go on the boat it gets the seal is
this a new video since it's a new video
once you bring it out for a second
where'd you see it on be on Instagram oh
right white grab seal on what if you can
do it by new that's or we can actually
filter the times that's it
this red top one yep that's it okay this
is a newer video twice a swatches 2017
oh that's an old video but this one
you're sure right back oh there's a
shark
she'll chill I don't know he seems like
he's totally fine where's the people
they were chumming the water and then
there was a seal now watch this
I hear people how's it oh there he goes
yeah they usually like to stay close to
the shark now they should go in circles
around his tail Oh Oh God in there you
should wait that's too a person
terrifying yeah see you there you know
it's tough how does Shark Week keep it
going
she's like I've seen that video that
could have been from last night so I'm
recording it it's the same [ __ ] every
time House shark we keep the ratings up
I don't the same [ __ ] people are faster
than the Sharks yeah me too
I love Shark Week but it's the same
every it's the same [ __ ] every year yet
we watch it Miami there's nothing new
with you they discover nothing new with
great whites in 200 years it's been the
same [ __ ] shark Wow the same video
every week hey do you play the same ones
every time years ago years way to play
the same watch it [ __ ] pipe it up on the
boat let's recap this and then real
shitty out motion real shitty act and
let's recap exactly well I was walking
and then I you know we got in the water
it's always dusk or dawn every shark
attack every shark attack story starts
like this we got in the water today goes
I mean look it was a beautiful day we
got in the water and it was dusk and
they were elephant seals everywhere and
I saw dorsal fin no there's no water
boys sure you hear a lot about it but
you know everything's gonna happen look
at that [ __ ] look at that picture of
that gray white coming out of the water
about what a monster oh my [ __ ] god
just a giant fish mm-hm I don't get how
Shark Week keeps going man what else
gets in alright this it's a killing
machine okay alright this is just a
small clip if you guys heard this or not
during the fights the corner man for
Rashad Colter yeah I just play for you
guys if it please
that's refresh rate and this is on
barstool sports well maybe it's not
gonna play yeah all he says is you're
not gonna knock him out
he's big old Mexican he's got big old
head and the way is that what's the
craziest thing you ever heard in the
corner was there anything you ever had
like any foreign matter we go all right
guys big he's very strong stay away from
his God not really my coach were pretty
on it they're not very funny no no not
really
all right I want you to quit
let's get Jim all right this one is
pretty crazy this guy Lou
Luke Heimlich apparently he was supposed
to like he was supposed to go into the
NBA I'm sorry NBA MLB MLB Draft and if
he's like a really good pop-up prospect
however he has something on his record
for child molestation can't draft he was
15 years old and I guess is his niece
said that he touched her some places
whatever and a he's saying he's saying
that he was given bad legal advice from
the scene yeah
Oh to just accept this aseptically oh no
no something happened so now he's to
come to this for like amazing baseball
player but no one wants to draft him and
did they did they find anything d'action
molest his niece or what's going on I
mean so he was convicted he had to go to
you know all the stuff you say yes I did
yeah he's 15 years old
look who's ready for the best prospect
in the draft [ __ ] how old was his niece
six years eight or something like that
it's tough tonight me if y'all see
Melissa it's a family thing his family
says it's the best way for our family to
move on yeah I don't know man if I was
that eight my dad would not die just
take the police so he moved on I don't
know
I'm suspect I don't know any I don't
know I don't know enough details yeah we
can't be molesting kids getting drafted
though yeah
you know he was also a kid how old was
his niece the whole thing is was she 14
was she 13 you know she 18 yeah I don't
know any detail so I'm not a little
sketchy though yeah the family going
just please
yes and then guilty and then let's move
on yeah and why no if so try accuse me
not my dad like the [ __ ] we are let's
get on your record mom man yeah well
it's supposed to go away from your
record it's actually supposed to when
you're a juvenile located it is not
supposed to be on your record as an
adult so it's supposed to be sealed
mm-hmm okay melt yeah then it's not
supposed to affect your future
employment see that's why this stuff I
need more details one thing about they
live under the one it's sealed they will
they can still find it all first of
course kill me especially this day and
age yeah in the 60s you've been fine
yeah one sixties years moved to another
parish what else your chin did this is
not a huge deal but it looks funny
such shrunken pence never seen this be
no offenses like oh [ __ ] moves in things
like literally right after he does it so
no one else does it first lady members
of his cabinet showed up at a meeting of
the fimo today a meeting to give a
briefing on this year's hurricane season
that began on Friday so he grabs water
ball puts it down intense immediately
puts his water ball down but this is
them making fun of them it was just but
it seemed like pants solid though maybe
just did it doesn't know where you saw
it it's you yeah I don't know maybe it's
like something maybe they have a thing
whatever you do I'm gonna do or whatever
you do that means let's get the [ __ ] out
yes let's wrap this idea sighs yeah
that's interesting and this is a skit
that they get any problem
they have a lot of work to be ready for
catastrophic disasters specifically the
anyway funny good - there's not many
awesome ones here how about this right
here okay so have you have you guys ever
returned stuff from Amazon never never I
don't return stuff too much of a hassle
oh crap that a whole like you know I'm
ordering a Casper mattress yeah and well
my wife is like I was like so we get the
the top of the line one or get the
middle one decide to get the middle one
and she goes if we don't like it we'll
just return and get the better when I go
back at 1/2 oh not gonna happen unless
they come into my house come all the way
upstairs now then I still gotta make a
phone - I have to call nope yeah was
like I was at CVS that's so hard at CVS
buying Clippers for my son and the lady
goes you already see I go oh no I'm good
she goes you want to take this because
if those if they try to I'm too lazy for
that no I just don't Clippers Clippers
don't work it's too much of a house you
know deal with us even when I bought
when I get my I buy my tickets on
Expedia and it says do you want to do
you want to insure your trip nope no
nothing I gotta I gotta mark that off
but Clippers I bought Clippers and I
came back home to use them and there's
hair on him of course I'm returning
those things really see I would have
dust that here off like a man and me get
back to my car drag the I'm blowing on
it boy found a scalp pieces of scalp and
I would've been like you know what you
know alcohol goes in used heroin needle
my man will be alright yeah sorry she's
gonna enter my body that's true do that
I'm like oh god even when I had to
return my rental car and I knew that I
had I'd used a quarter tank and I knew
they were gonna charge me up the ass for
to fill it up because I didn't get by
still and I was like I just can't stop
with the mean either like do it's a
hassle to stop every time I do
never [ __ ] on the way back I told you
had to buy that that my ticket on Delta
and I didn't I had to buy it last minute
to go back to LA from Raleigh and I got
stuck in the middle seat between two of
the biggest human beings on the planet
both who smelled like like a zoo they
smelled like a hamster cage and it was a
situation it sucked
okay so what about the speaking stuff
back Jen so well I've returned stuff on
Amazon before for whatever reason they
didn't work or whatever but Amazon has
this policy where if you get something
and doesn't work or if it's broken then
they'll replace it for you so this
couple would continue to do this thing
where they would say something's broken
and they would give him another item for
free said they would have two items and
then we sell those items so they did it
to over two thousand four seven hundred
pieces of equipment
yeah they got investigated obviously
there's two thousand 1.2 million dollars
worth of stuff the Hustle is real so
they're going to jail for six years Wow
hope that was worth it you six years six
years I have full-time job do you get a
real job ton of work mmm yeah the only
time I'll take stuff back it's a long
time to go to jail to ya know you might
suck those people yeah they're alright
be bad people yeah if I get shoes if
they don't fit right even then if I were
from X lock like you just got these
Jordan cactuses these Travis cots I hope
they fit they don't fit right there's
like just repackage them send them back
and I was find a friendly because I
don't know how cuz it because repack is
then you have to take it to the UPS know
Amazon you don't do that you just to
like tape it back up and they come pick
it up I'm like oh you and I'll just go
go [ __ ] and then I just put this on
forget it you and I when we have to take
a shuttle like if Brenner I have to take
a shuttle to the rental car I don't do
it anymore
it's I paid a cab I don't know what
happened I go pegye because it's
expensive I gotta take a I don't care
it's worth it I can't get on the shuttle
can't do the shot it makes you depressed
I get depressed I stop flying I think it
was Delta or
because you have to take a shuttle from
the LAX now that's American yes I want
to America anymore cuz you have to you
go through regular security ha so then
you go go down here till you get through
security right for the bow down here
wait for the shuttle I'm gonna have to
drag up a terrible satellite [ __ ]
terminal get terminal that just sells
like water and hum yes
they got homeless a couple of magazines
and a [ __ ] compass I'm out American
amount I'm oh so depressing no I get it
with you guys can you guys travel all
the time so after a while
no it gets to me to the house it does
get to me if it shuttles it won't do
yeah flying out why not first class from
my family though it's simply too
expensive so I'll be dubby and Delta
comfort Hawaii though if you wanted man
Hawaii that it gen that sit man
attention I take some [ __ ] back man come
see me in Raleigh North Carolina I mean
no come on portal is like you're bad god
damn it come see me in Portland
I got Portland helium great spot man
June 21 22 23 next week
yep I got Syracuse and Tampa in July and
then we gotta haul Wow
thank you some Tim yeah that's the two
weekends before I get to saw a hawk with
you can't be improv Tampa have you been
there no I love Tampa and fantastic and
then I got Syracuse and urban Syracuse
you have funny bone yep how was that
yeah so I'll be at ha I will be I look
funny months so I will be at ice Tuesday
night I'm with Triple E and Rogaine and
the boys at the Comedy Store - ow [ __ ]
yeah your gun so doesn't matter
and then I'm with drew my stamp on the
spot this Tuesday night Friday night I'm
at the ice house I think that shows sold
out and then next week Friday Saturday
at Houston Houston improv and then July
7th come do come watch me to our of
stand up and then I'm doing the early
show so I will stay and watch the fights
with you guys joy seventh that's
Oklahoma Cherokee Casino it's one night
when she only those tickets are super
limited because I'm watching the fights
with you guys so they lowered the ticket
so your tickets now f @k calm then
tickets for Spokane
and Austin just went on sale as well cap
seeing Austin first time there t fat K
calm see you guys out there be up on why
you [ __ ] thanks buddy
i lo hi everybody this now is the fire
kid we're out